IRAN AND WE BEGIN WITH
JOHN ROBERTS ON THE MAJOR
MOVEMENT OF NORTH KOREA.
GOOD EVENING.
>> AS HE WAS BOARDING
AIR FORCE ONE ON HIS WAY TO A
CAMPAIGN RALLY THIS AFTERNOON,
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREDICTED THAT
HIS PENDING SETTLEMENT WITH
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG UN
WOULD BE A "GREAT SUCCESS."
THE CHANCES OF IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENING WERE GREATLY ENHANCED
BY THE FACT THAT NORTH KOREA
RELEASED THE THREE REMAINING
AMERICAN PRISONERS THAT THEY
WERE HOLDING.
IT WAS JUST AFTER 3:00 IN THE
MORNING THAT THE THREE AMERICANS
DID OBTAIN NORTH KOREA TOUCHED
DOWN IN JOINT BASE ANDREWS, THE
VICE PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND THE FIRST LADY WERE ALL ON
HOME TO WELCOME THEM HOME.
>> CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE GOODWILL GESTURE WAS
ENOUGH TO SEAL THE DEAL ON A
TRUMP-KIM SUMMIT.
THE PRESIDENTS WEEDING THE
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED MEETING
BETWEEN KIM JONG UN AND MYSELF
WILL TAKE PLACE IN SINGAPORE ON
JUNE 12TH, WE WILL BOTH TRY TO
MAKE IT A VERY SPECIAL MOMENT
FOR WORLD PEACE.
THE DATE CARRIES HISTORIC
SIGNIFICANCE BRIDGE JUNE 12TH
1987 THAT RONALD REAGAN GAVE A
SPEECH IN WEST GERMANY.
A SPEECH THAT SET THE STAGE FOR
THE FALL OF THE SOVIET UNION.
>> MR. GORBACHEV TEAR DOWN THIS
WALL.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY THE
CHOICE OF JUNE 12TH WAS SIMPLY A
COINCIDENCE.
BUT AS PRESIDENT REAGAN FOUND,
PRESIDENT TRUMP BELIEVES THAT
KIM JONG UN WILL WANT TO CHOOSE
A PATH OUT OF ISOLATION.
>> I REALLY THINK THAT HE WANTS
TO DO SOMETHING.
I THINK THAT HE DID THIS BECAUSE
HE REALLY WANTS TO DO SOMETHING,
AND BRING THE COUNTRY INTO THE
REAL WORLD.
>> IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP HIM
MOVING TOWARDS THE BARGAINING
TABLE, DROPPING THE HARSH
RHETORIC OF LITTLE ROCKET MAN,
GOING SO FAR TO PRAISE HIM FOR
RELEASING THE DETAINEES.
>> I WANT TO THANK KIM JONG UN
WHO REALLY WAS EXCELLENT TO WITH
THE THREE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
>> THE COMPLEMENT BROUGHT SHARP
CRITICISM FROM THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER.
>> THE EXULTATION OF THE
GREATNESS OF NORTH KOREA DOING
THIS EVADES ME.
WE CANNOT BE FOOLED INTO GIVING
THE NORTH KOREAN REGIME CREDIT.
FOR RETURNING AMERICANS THAT
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN DETAINED
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> IN RESPONSE TO CHUCK SCHUMER,
THE HOUSE SPEAKER SAID, GIVE THE
PRESIDENT A BREAK.
>> HE IS PREPARING FOR A SUMMIT
WITH THE LEADER OF NORTH KOREA
TO FOCUS ON DENUCLEARIZATION.
WE SHOULD GIVE HIM SOME LEEWAY.
>> WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKED
THE IDEA OF THE DMZ WHERE KIM
AND SOUTH KOREA'S
PRESIDENT MATZ, SINGAPORE WAS
ALWAYS THE FIRST CHOICE OF THE.
CLOSE ENOUGH FOR HIM TO GET TO
WITH THE LIMITED FLEET OF
AIRCRAFT AT THE NEUTRAL
TERRITORY.
A CITY RENOWNED FOR EXCELLENT
SECURITY.
>> JUST ABOUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE
THE SUMMONS, SINGAPORE HOSTS AN
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY
CONFERENCE WHERE DELEGATES COME
FROM ALL OVER THE INDO PACIFIC
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES TO
TALK ABOUT MUTUAL SECURITY
NEEDS.
SO I THINK THAT IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE.
IT IS AN IDEAL LOCATION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD HIS EYE
ON DOMESTIC ISSUES TODAY,
SPECIFICALLY THE FARM BILL IN
THE WHITE HOUSE MEETING TODAY
WITH THE AGRICULTURE SECRETARY
SONNY PURDUE, PAT ROBERTS OF
KANSAS, AND MIKE CONAWAY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE
EXPECTS WHEN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IS DRAFTED THAT IT WILL
INCLUDE MEASURES THAT WOULD
REQUIRE WORK FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON FOOD STAMPS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE
EXPECTS SAID TO BE IN THE
LEGISLATION, HE STOPPED SHORT OF
ISSUING WHAT WAS EXPECTED TO BE
A VETO TREND.
>> Bret: THERE IS A STORY IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HEADLINED
NORTH SECURITY CLOSE TO
RESIGNING AFTER TRUMP BERATED
HER AND TALKS ABOUT AN INCIDENT,
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT IN
THE CABINET MEETING YESTERDAY, I
HAVE CONFIRMED THIS THROUGH
SOURCES, KIRSTJEN NIELSEN FELT
LIKE SHE WAS SINGLED OUT AND
PARADED BY THE PRESIDENT OVER
WHAT HE SAW AS A LACK OF BORDER
SECURITY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT SAYS
THAT SHE WAS CLOSE TO RESIGNING
OVER IT AND THAT SHE HAD DRAFTED
A LETTER OF RESIGNATION.
WHAT WE ARE HEARING FROM SOURCES
AT DHS IS THAT A TWEET WILL BE
COMING SOON.
THAT WOULD DENY THE EXISTENCE OF
A RESIGNATION LETTER.
IT MAY BE THAT SHE WAS SAYING
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF WELL,
IF I'M NOT DOING A GOOD JOB,
MAYBE I SHOULD NOT BE IN THIS
JOB.
BUT AS FAR AS DRAFTING A FORMAL
RESIGNATION LETTER, THAT APPEARS
TO NOT BE THE CASE AT LEAST